oh here we go here we go it's um
psychobabble again you know the drill
you know the drill bit I see another
drill we're doing this game called
virtual morality Episode one who killed
any luck hey I'm Sarah now if a dispatch
nobody knows this one probably this
one's and this one does even know what's
going on here and who's this okay we'll
find out who those mystery girls in a
second let's do this
Marquez I am better than this I'm better
than all these people laugh at Marcus
he's a dork yes no Tara laughing here
match oh yes Marcus this guy has some
fun okay
yeah yeah
party mode vision I sing hello ladies
hey I think yeah I'ma be any bad chess
oh that's Holly it's Abby okay get used
to it okay
that guy
yeah you better watch your mouth okay
hey I'm a bike that's that's mr. girl
i everybody's phones are lighting up oh
my god don't share don't like don't
subscribe um don't forget to hit the
like button somebody got cut
Ziggy shut up okay
sex yeah oh I just missed it what the
heck I thought I supposed to press okay
hello sir
it's all a video when I say down here
well this party is this is where the
party stop and it's just like my party
heart I can you know okay I love [ __ ]
that smoke yes let me take up yeah I've
got a gay gay gay nobody no nothing
important let's just keep partying
yes follow in his face dance dance dance
[Applause]
[Music]
well this guy is so fun like why I
couldn't have my bride came here in the
first place
sure beats Marcus ja I want some what is
that
and now why bro not right now I'm having
a batch okay it's your loss oh my god
Zig a they're gay
are you there are you sleeping where the
move will party thank ya thank ya yes
I'm good good good
thank ya no everyone hears great
who's this spacious did
[Music]
oh my god Holly
I'll be sleeping oh my god my video
sprinters great okay great okay
next episode one
like is that okay I guess that's that
that's Han thank ya